nous accueillons nicolas glières
enseignants et membres des styles rouge
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous 500
millions d'euros de hausse des salaires
des enseignants dès 2021 pourra
compenser les effets de la réforme des
retraites malgré cette annonce vous
continuer la mobilisation ne m'a encore
plus ces 500 millions paraissent une
énorme somme c'est vrai nous sommes
880000 enseignants mais cela est fait
comme vous venez de le dire pour
compenser entre guillemets cette réforme
des retraites très injuste la preuve il
faut la compenser donc c'est 500
millions ne suffisent pas cela va juste
permettre de compenser l'inflation qui
est de 1,6 à 2 % à peu près par an mais
tout ce qu'on a perdu depuis près de 40
ans depuis 83 comme je le répète sans
arrêt ses 40% qu'on nous doit
concrètement ne sont toujours pas
rattrapé en gros on a une espèce de
chantage
on fait passer de force une réforme
injuste pour tous
on épargne les catégories qu'on veut
préserver la police qu'on laisse un peu
d'ailleurs mal se comporter avec les
manifestants y ait de plus en plus
d'image qui tourne c'est un scandale
voilà là y'a peut-être aucun problème
alors là où les bons ou les épargnes on
épargne militaire on n'a pas envie
d'avoir une émeute
on va épargner les sénateurs parce que
quand même ces gens ces grands
privilégiés on va quand même pas les
toucher mais elle a en revanche les
autres catégories de population les
salariés du privé du public
les profs concrètement eux ou les la
mine
vous l'avez rappelé cette hausse des
salaires était une était demandée depuis
plusieurs années par le corps enseignant
est ce que malgré tout ce n'est pas une
bonne nouvelle un premier pas positif
alors ce qui est certain c'est que nous
avons réussi depuis un an à faire entrer
dans les têtes que nous étions mal payé
et ce n'est pas une vue de l'esprit
une réalité dont concrètement ce chiffre
de 10 milliards
c'est ce que nous demandons depuis un an
laisse tes le rouge et les syndicats se
sont joints à nous pour demander cette
somme
le problème c'est qu'elle était demandée
sans compensation puisque cet argent
qu'on nous devait depuis 83 encore une
fois la bonne ou la lie à cette réforme
parce qu'on va avoir une énorme baisse
donc en fait ça ne rattrape rien on
continue à avoir le point d'indicé est
gelé
l'inflation continue à grimper le
logement notamment en ile-de-france
atteint des prix terrifiant pour
n'importe quel c
et que ce soit la location et encore
plus à l'achat on ne peut pas bien vivre
de notre métier et j'imagine pour
d'autres métiers qui seront plus grande
difficulté
je pense aussi aux aides-soignants aux
infirmières c'est même chose les
concertations sont prévus dans un
premier temps jusqu'à ce jeudi
plus largement jusqu'au mois de mars
plusieurs rencontres sont donc prévues
avec notamment le ministère de
l'éducation qu'est ce que vous en
attendez qu est ce que vous allez
demander alors les syndicats vont
demander toujours les mêmes choses de
revendications une portant les mêmes
concrètement tous ensemble ce qu'on
attend du ministère simplement qu'ils se
débouche les oreilles que les ministres
notamment monsieur bhl ankara de mentir
à longueur de journée sur les plateaux
sur un trafic et les chiffres à dévier
des chiffres de leurs destinations va
dire qu'il arrête de faire de la com
qu'il agisse qu'il réponde à nos
revendications sinon nous continuerons à
faire grave et très concrètement quelles
mesures annoncées par le ministère de
l'éducation jean michel blanc coeur
pourrait vous satisfaire davantage 10
milliards maintenant sans rapport avec
la réforme des retraites 10 milliards
dès pendant 17 ans mais 10 milliards
pour tous les fans de salaire et pour
tous les goûts 3,50 là il faut savoir
que c'est seulement pour ce à partir de
75 les autres ne seront juste pas
augmenté donc ça ne répond aucunement
aux revendications
la compensation annoncée par le
gouvernement ne s'annonce pas tellement
efficace selon vous c'est ce que vous
c'est ce que vous déclarez qu'est-ce qui
va se négocier là ces prochains jours
jusqu'à jusqu'à jeudi puisque on le
rappelle c'est un round de négociations
en plusieurs temps l'ensemble des
syndicats sont reçus ces trois jours
mais on en attend encore une fois je
sais que ça peut être lassant mais on en
attend pas grand chose nous les stylos
rouges pour la bonne et simple raison
que le ministère et le gouvernement sont
dans la même stratégie
il dit ce sur quoi on peut discuter ce
n'est pas une négociation
ce n'est pas une discussion ce n'est pas
une écoutiez n'écoute rien du tout ils
suivent leurs plans prévus depuis le
début en collaboration avec certains
syndicats ramolli
comme la cfdt et l'unsa qui ont prévu
déjà cette histoire d'âge pivot qui est
une arnaque totale et il ne donne rien
d'autre on ne peut pas discuter sur
d'autres points donc la seule discussion
c'est le rapport de force
merci d'être venus réagir sur notre
plateau n'est que la cuillère
enseignants et membres des stylos rouges
merci à vous